as the attorney representing Adrienne's
trust I'm required to read a prepared
statement Cecelia although our
relationship was far from perfect I
thought that you would talk to me rather
than run away okay what happened to him
he cut his wrists for his final wishes
you're getting five million dollars
contingent of course on the fine print
it can't be a rule to be mentally
incompetent it just doesn't make any
sense
what Adrienne wouldn't kill himself
listen getting your freedom back okay
don't let him haunt you
[Music]
[Music]
I'm scared we don't have to be scared of
him anymore he was a sociopath
completely in control of everything he
said that wherever I went he would find
me walk right up to me and I wouldn't be
able to see him okay someone sitting in
that chair they found something they
can't prove what I'm experiencing you
need help Adrian is dead I went to his
house today
he's not dead I have a pile of ashes in
the box that but disagree with you he
has figured out a way to be invisible
only thing more brilliant than inventing
something that makes you invisible then
it was coming up with the perfect way to
torture you even in death
Adrian's true genius was how he got in
people's heads don't come any closer
crazy you're saying the person trying to
kill you
is in the room right now but we can't
see him
[Music]
[Music]
who you are
[Music]
you